well they come right down wanted this
way go in the chicken no let's do it but
do it quickly please I know you want to
stick on him as soon as he finishes come
over to me well I think if there was any
doubt that the Gaddafi regime was not
under pressure than that statement for
mr. Ibrahim shows very clearly that they
are coming under extreme pressure in
Tripoli the rebel front managed to get
as close as fifteen hunters of the West
and gate the entrance to Tripoli just
well less than half an hour ago they
encountered some resistance and they
pulled back here to Maya but they are
still turning around using their
converted civilian vehicles mounted with
military weapons on the back to again
push forward they're in a state of flux
at the moment because they are still
coming under fire from cybers who are
positioned along the road further
further down and people are a little
because it is unpredictable down there
but however they feel very much that the
momentum is still on their side and as I
say despite turning around about 60 or
so vehicles and really going help never
out away from Tripoli they have
challenged around again but they are
still being attacked they're still being
attacked by snipers and that is what's
causing some concern whoever this there
is a pair amount of tails anyway in any
sort of hostile environment any sort of
war-torn atmosphere they've still got
numbers and weaponry on their side and a
lot of it you can see in the background
maybe not they all the commanders and
the people who are trying to run their
little units are desperately trying to
calm people everyone's a bit edgy
everyone's a little bit nervous because
they encountered a bit of resistance at
the 27th gate but they keep on trying to
say calm calm don't pull back any
further don't go back any further we've
got to stand firm and we've got to put
on
[Music]
okay thank you okay going
Darwin finish finish